a new report says a wealthy Republican
donor owns the house where Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas's mother lives
he bought it from Thomas and his family
and the News organization propublica
says the Justice never reported it as
required by law it's the first
confirmation that Thomas directly
received money from the influential man
that he calls a close friend Jan
Crawford has more
a conservative Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas is under scrutiny for
the second time this month after
pro-publica reported on undisclosed
Financial ties to Republican Mega donor
Harlan Crowe CBS News can confirm
pro-publicly's reporting that Crow's
company purchased properties belonging
to Thomas and members of his family in
his hometown of Savannah Georgia the
undisclosed 2014 deal included the
purchase of a home and two vacant lots
for more than a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars that made Crow the
owner of the home Thomas's mother lived
in that later underwent tens of
thousands of dollars worth of
Renovations but Thomas didn't report the
sale despite a federal disclosure law
partly designed to help avoid conflicts
of interest that law indicates justices
should report most real estate deals
over one thousand dollars Maximus told
us it appears that Thomas very clearly
violated the law Joshua Kaplan is one of
the reporters who wrote the story I
think one of the root issues here is
that the Supreme Court has very very
very little transparency and very very
little oversight compared to essentially
every other part of the federal
government and the justices have been
you know essentially almost entirely
left to police themselves Crow said in a
statement that he bought it to one day
create a public museum at the Thomas
home this Revelation comes on the heels
of a report last week Thomas accepted
luxury vacations over the past two
decades paid for by crow in a statement
following that report Thomas said he was
advised that this sort of personal
Hospitality from close personal friends
who did not have business before the
court was not reportable Senate
Democrats in support of more
transparency from the court like Rhode
Island's Sheldon White House are calling
on Chief Justice John Roberts to launch
an Ethics investigation and refer Thomas
to the attorney general for
investigation for CBS morning's Jan
Crawford Washington